what exactly is a Grimace I mean mayor
MC cheese was obviously a cheeseburger
birdie is a McChicken and they're even
talking McNuggets and trash bins so name
you can't forget with social media
making it easier than ever for fandoms
to connect online people began to
speculate about what happened to Grimace
other than a rumored appearance at a
Dodger game in 2012 he seems to have
just vanished from public life Grimace
is the embodiment of a milkshake though
others still insist he's a taste bud so
the two options here are rather uh Grim
either he's a milkshake who drinking
milkshakes thus making the grimaces
cannibals or he's a taste bud which
means any bodily contact you have with
him is him tasting you don't touch
grimace